HIS RECORD, 55-0.
HERE WITH MORE THE FOUNDER
TRAVIS WITH US WITH THE AUTHOR
OF THE BIG NEW BOOK BATTLE FOR
THE AMERICAN MIND UPROOTING
ESSENTIALLY OF MISEDUCATION
FOX & FRIENDS WE CAN HOST HIS
FIRST CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
BOOK.
Amazon.com WILL THROW IT UP
ON Hannity.com.
IF YOU LOOK AT THIS ONE ISSUE I
UNDERSTAND WHY DEMOCRATS ARE
DOING WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
THEY ARE ALL THESE OTHER ISSUES
THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT.
ROE V. WADE IF IT DOES GO AWAY
THE STATES WILL DECIDE WITH THE
LAWS WILL BE.
I DOUBT IF ANY STATES WILL
TOTALLY COMPLETELY OUTLAW
ABORTION, NOTHING THAT CAN
HAPPEN.
IF THEY DID PEOPLE WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO NEIGHBORING STATES
NEW YORK, CALIFORNIA, OR ANY
OTHER PLACE WANT TO GO IS THAT
CORRECT?
>> THAT IS CORRECT THE FAR LEFT
EXTREMIST SHIFT IS SYNCING WITH
JOE BIDEN AT THE HELM.
THEY KNOW IT.
THEY BELIEVE THAT THIS CRIMINAL
LEAK OF A POTENTIAL DRAFT OF A
SUPREME COURT DECISION IS THERE
LIFE RAFT AND THEY ARE CLINGING
TO IT AND SCREAMING FROM THE
HILLTOPS.
THEY JUST DECLARED THAT YOU, ME,
I DON'T SPEAK FOR CLAY BUT I
PRESUME THAT CLAY AND EVERYONE
ELSE WHO IS SUPPORT THE POLICIES
OF DONALD TRUMP OR BELIEVE IN
AMERICA FIRST IS THE MOST
EXTREME MOVEMENT IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
THEY HAVE PEGGED AND MAXED A
RHETORICAL RESPONSE AND AS YOU
POINTED OUT THE BITTER CLEANERS
OF BARACK OBAMA TO THE BASKET OF
DEPLORABLE'S TO HILLARY CLINTON.
THAT TYPE OF DEMAGOGUERY DOESN'T
WORK POLITICALLY AS WELL.
AND TO HEAR KAMALA HARRIS SAY
HOW DARE YOU, ONLY THING THAT
DOES IS MAKE VOTERS SAY WHERE IS
THAT PASSION ON ANY OTHER SINGLE
ISSUE?
IT ONLY REMINDS VOTERS IN THE
ELECTRIC THAT THE ONLY THING
THEY CARE ABOUT IS ABORTING
BABIES OR CHILDREN AS JOE BIDEN
ADMITTED AS OPPOSED TO
ADDRESSING THINGS THAT ARE
CROSSING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
RIGHT NOW.
SO IT SHOWS THE LEFT AND THE
EXTREMIST THAT THEY ARE AND I
DON'T THINK THAT IT'LL BE
EFFECTIVE BUT IT'S TRAGIC, HERE
WE ARE.
DEMONIZING THE PRESIDENT, ONCE
OUT OF THE POLITICAL AISLE
EFFECTIVELY IS TERRIBLE.
>> Hannity: I'M PRO-LIFE CLAY
I DO MAKE EXCEPTIONS, SOME
PEOPLE DISAGREE WITH ME.
RAPE, --
THEY SAY THAT THEY'RE PRO-CHOICE
BUT THEY WILL ALWAYS SAY THAT
ABORTION SHOULD BE RARE, AND IT
SHOULD BE FIRST TRIMESTER.
WHAT IS HAPPEN WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY MANY OF THESE
BLUE STATES I LIST THEM LAST
NIGHT, THEY ACTUALLY ALLOW
ABORTIONS UP TILL THE MOMENT OF
BIRTH AND THEN OF COURSE THOSE
COMMENTS POST BIRTH ABORTION
WITH HIS MURDER.
I THINK THEY'VE GONE SO HARD
CORE RADICAL ON THIS ISSUE THAT
THEY ARE THE ONES OUT OF TOUCH,
BUT THE 67% OF AMERICANS THINK
IT SHOULD BE LEGAL BUT THINK
THAT THERE SHOULD BE
RESTRICTIONS FOR EXAMPLE
MISSISSIPPI IS SAYING 15 WEEKS
MAX.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> I AGREE WITH THE VAST
MAJORITIES OF THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC AND LAW WITH WHAT YOU
JUST SAID SEAN ENOS WAS GOING ON
HERE.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WE JUST
SPENT BASICALLY A YEAR AND A
HALF ALL OF JOE BIDEN'S A
ADMINISTRATION ARGUING THAT
DEMOCRACY IS UNDER SIEGE, IS NOW
OUTRAGED THAT NINE UNELECTED
JUSTICES ARE POISED TO SAY HEY,
LET'S LET 50 STATES DECIDE WHAT
THE LAW SHOULD BE SO THAT ALL OF
YOUR STATE REPRESENTATIVES, ALL
OF YOUR STATE SENATORS, AND YOUR
GOVERNORS OF BOTH POLITICAL
PARTIES CAN HAVE A ROBUST DEBATE
AND FIGURE OUT THE APPROPRIATE
POLICY AND EVERY STATE.
SO THAT THINKS THE FEDERALISM WE
CANNOT 50 STATE LABORATORIES.
I WENT TO LAW SCHOOL SEAN,
ANYONE WHO READS THE ROE V. WADE
OPINION, ALMOST UNANIMOUSLY
REGARDLESS OF THEIR POLITICAL
OPINION IF YOU TAKE AWAY WHAT
THE RESULT IS AGREES THAT IT'S
AN AWFUL OPINION.
YOU QUOTED RUTH BADER GINSBURG
SAYING AS MUCH AND SHE CERTAINLY
AGREES THAT ABORTION SHOULD BE
LEGAL.
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE IS THAT
WE ARE HOLDING DEMOCRACY
ACCOUNTABLE FOR 49 YEARS WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO HAVE A REAL DEBATE
SEAN AND I THINK THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT.
IT'S OFTEN ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THE SUPREME COURT SHOULD BE
LEGALIZING ABORTION IN SOME WAY,
NOW IT'S ABOUT WHETHER YOUR
INDIVIDUAL STATE AND WHETHER YOU
WANT TO SUPPORT PEOPLE ON EITHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE, THAT IS WHAT
SHOULD BE HAPPENING HERE, THIS
IS DEMOCRACY FLOURISHING, THIS
IS JUDICIAL RESTRAINT, THIS IS
THE OPPOSITE OF JUDICIAL
ACTIVISM, THIS IS A DEMOCRACY IN
ACTION YOU WOULD THINK THE
DEMOCRATS REMEMBER SEAN WASN'T
TOO LONG AGO ON THE
SUPREME COURT WITH A STOOD UP
AND SAID EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN
HAS TO GET A COVERT SHOT OR YOU
LOSE YOUR JOB.
NOW THEY DON'T WANT DEMOCRACY TO
WORK ON THIS ISSUE DOESN'T ADD
UP.
>> Hannity: IT SO IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU.
ALSO CONGRATS ON THE NE